figurez vous que si on lâche une mouche
elle ne va pas forcément s'envoler elle
peut aussi tomber et s'écraser bon voire
une mouche tomber comme ça dans la
nature ça reste assez exceptionnel ces
images ont été produites au cours d'une
expérience menée par des chercheurs de
l'institut des sciences du mouvement de
marseille ils ont voulu étudier le vol
de la mouche a plus précisément comment
ce petit insecte contrôler sa
trajectoire lorsqu'il est en chute libre
le protocole est simple il fixe la
mouche au sommet d'une boîte
grâce à un petit bout d'épingler collé
sur son dos tout en vérifiant que ça ne
m'empêche pas de voler il lâche ensuite
la mouche d'un seul coup du haut de la
boîte et enregistre sa trajectoire grâce
à une caméra ultrarapide
voilà ce que ça donne dans un
environnement noir on voit qu'elle a
réagi à sa chute elle galère pour
attraper sa trajectoire
bwin elle s'écrase dans un environnement
entièrement blanc elle se réveille plus
tôt mais elle galère encore et robin
elle s'écrase en revanche dans un
environnement à rayures elle se réveille
très vite elle se repère et elle reprend
son envol
c'est toi manip dure moins d'une seconde
et elle montre que la mouche se repère
dans l'espace avant tout grâce à sa vue
contrairement à nous elle n'a pas
d'oreille interne qui lui permettrait de
se sentir ces mouvements une sa position
dans l'espace
elle n'est donc pas sensible à la
gravité ou plutôt à l'absence de gravité
vous savez cette agréable sensation que
l'on est en chute libre
voilà donc on a regardé les mouches
voler oui bon en fait non en plus de
mieux comprendre la physiologie de la
mouche
cette découverte permet par exemple
d'imaginer des systèmes de pilote
automatique pour des drones avec moins
de capteurs qui utilise uniquement des
caméras pour contrôler leur trajectoire
donc on peut dire que c'est un sujet qui
fait mouche quoi vous attendiez mieux
comme chute et n'oublie pas à bonn toi